the much anticipated new york
international auto show opens to the
public tomorrow the event is the most
attended car show in the world more than
a million visitors will see about a
thousand cars SUVs and trucks Tim
Stevens is editor-in-chief of the
automotive website road show at our
partners cnet and he joins us now Tim
good morning morning can we first talked
about this car out front with the Jack
Russell terrier having the time of his
life that is Nissan's concept car the
rogue dough dough goes on here too so
this is basically the next step you know
we've got minivans to take care of your
kids now we need something to take care
of your pets and so nice on created this
concept they basically put all the pet
friendly stuff you could ever want in
the back of this road was a ramp so your
dog can get up you get a smaller dog or
like me an older dog there's actually a
water tank in the back with a washer so
you can wash your dog if it gets dirty
there's a dryer and a vacuum back there
so if it spills its kibble you can pick
that up it's got a little Bowl that
folds out from the side there's even a
place to put your your poop bags in the
side too Wow it has everything is this
catering to a certain kind of consumer
here actually looks don't need right
here those who really treat their fur
babies well we'll definitely want a car
like this even the river cameras have
been tildes you can see your dog hanging
the head of the window which is what we
want to see anybody I'm interested in
speed of colors that's okay four cars
for cars let's empower okay that's
important to clarify this thing Kevin
bet the Dodge Challenger so we're
talking about the demon which is the new
appropriately named version the
Challenger it is evil and it is
absolutely awesome it is the quickest
and the fastest production car in the
quarter-mile ever will cover the
quarter-mile in just nine point six five
seconds at its top speed of 140 miles an
hour it is so quick it will actually
lift the front wheels off the ground
when it launches it gets to zero to 60
and 2.3 second point three seconds it'll
pull almost 2 g's on a launch which is
pretty outrageous it is ridiculously
fast and this is a production car so we
rolling off the showroom floor it can do
all these things pretty amazing the
passenger seat is optionally had to pay
extra dollar if you want to passenger
seat to see wait wow what about SUVs a
lot of SUVs on the show floor we just
actually awarded our world car of the
year yesterday and all three of our
finalists were SUVs for the first time
ever the winner was the jaguar f pace
but that shows that there's a lot of
interest in crossover suvs these small
suvs are kind of bridging the gap but
sedans and your full-size SUVs why is
that happening given the fact that the
industry so focus on fuel efficiency it
it is a really interesting dichotomy
right now that we are seeing cards
getting bigger and taller but they're
also getting lighter we see a lot more
advanced manufacturing techniques high
tensile strength steel steel excuse me
aluminum carbon fiber that allow these
bigger cars to be lighter and they still
drive a lot like a smaller car but you
have the higher perspective you're
sitting up taller a lot of people feel
safer in a call when you make the fact
that Tesla has a higher market cap that
neither Ford or GM it's definitely an
interesting thing out we're seeing
investors really looking down the road
five years ten years down the road and
thinking that if Tesla can pull off the
model 3 and can capitalize on all the
success of the model 3 they can really
blow up in a big big way you know right
now obviously Tesla doesn't have
anywhere near the sales other four of
them but these investors are being a
little bit optimistic and hoping down
the road they told Betty gonna come
exactly and did you wear that suit when
you he drove the three million dollar
Bugatti I know I should I just down a
little bit yes you do have a new look
thanks for the Auto Show everything's
new right now right doesn't it show
flora I was like what you were dressing
for us absolutely Charlie always in the
press I was lucky to draw this your own
if you about a month ago which is a
three-million-dollar Bugatti hypercar
1,500 horsepower about the power of
seven of your average sedans this car or
wear that suit for a car like that thank
you Tim my pleasure thank you